look we did the recap of what was good
last year so
what is there to look forward to this
time around
[Music]
so this is kind of interesting to uh to
do because i didn't do one of these for
2021 because after 2020 i had no faith
that anything was going to be released
when it was supposed to be
so i had a very strong gut feeling that
if i had done a list of the things i was
excited for in 2021 they were all going
to be pushed back to later and some of
them even did but in any case i'm
comfortable enough doing it this year
that having been said
this
it would be a little bit of an
overstatement to say that this is the
stuff i'm super excited for so we're
like this is the stuff that i plan to
check out and looks interesting there
isn't that much that i'm super pumped
for if i'm being honest and also i
should be clear this is going to be
mainstream entertainment heavy
there's probably going to be some good
smaller indie projects that i don't know
about looking over the list of films
planning to be released there's tons
that don't have trailers yet so i don't
have the first clue whether they look
any good so that means things with an
existing profile i.e franchises are
going to be carrying the bulk of the
weight on this also you're not gonna
find any video games on here because i
really am leaning heavier on the smaller
projects um the games that i really
liked uh that i played last year were
things like spirit fairer hades death
store and those aren't the kind of games
that get massive announcement months in
advance that they're going to be coming
out and the kind of games that do get
those announcements i don't play and
don't really want to
so this will be streaming and movies
primarily and i'm actually going to end
up lumping these into four major
categories
disney plus
netflix hbo max
and
theatrical releases now
i do actually have a couple more
services than that i have amazon prime
um i don't use it
that much for watching purposes
if i'm gonna be completely honest but
uh these are the things that i have i
don't have hulu i don't have paramount
plus i'm not really planning to dip into
either of those if i can help it i don't
need another bill
but between those that's what we're
going to be focusing on let's start with
disney plus so out of the things we know
that are coming this year there's a
couple of animated things that i'm
interested in one follow-up to a
long-time
ip that i'm quite curious about one more
or less new ip it's still part of marvel
that i am extremely excited about and
then one uh star wars property which
i'm hopeful for
let's say cautiously optimistic
sometimes that's the best you get out of
me on the animated front we've got
zootopia plus
and baymax
and both of these i'm mostly excited
because i think
what we've seen of these so far
lends itself to potentially very
interesting shows baymax i wasn't sure
that was what that was going to be
especially given that big hero 6 already
had an animated continuation we never
got a proper sequel which still annoys
me but this looks like it's going to
focus on baymax actually trying to help
people as what he was designed to be i.e
a medical assisting robot and i think
that has a wonderful potential for
interesting funny amusing potentially
heartfelt moments and interactions with
characters i am actually oddly more
interested in seeing that than in seeing
the continuations of the superhero
battling which is probably why i never
check out the big hero 6 tv show ah but
i think that sounds cute
although i will admit zootopia plus
sounds even more perfect cause zootopia
was a great setting i i like that movie
a lot i like that setting a lot and if
you're gonna go back to it um you know
i feel like the shorts might be the best
way to do it because if the if and when
they do another movie the presumption is
they're gonna focus on nick and judy
again which is going to mean it's going
to be some sort of police procedural or
at least that is going to factor into
the story whereas here you could pick
any neighborhood any character or any
species that lives in this world
and give us a completely different story
with them now i expect they'll all be
fairly light-hearted family-friendly and
um you know humorous in nature so i'm
not expecting like ooh and here's the
horror kind of story i don't expect it
to go that well but
i feel like the setting is broad enough
and wide enough that you can just
have these anthology shows where like
okay we're going to explore what it's
like here and here and here i think
that's a great way to flash it out even
further and really just have fun with
the setting in a way even more so than
the movie or any sequel would allow you
to do i think that's a neat idea we've
got willow coming up which i didn't like
the uh teaser trailer thing that they
did
last year but i grew up on willow i like
warwick davis i am
really super curious about this i don't
know how certain i am it's gonna be good
but boy do i wanna see it boy do i want
to see how they choose to move things
forward i mean the main thing for me is
i just hope they don't
sort of
overexpand willow's importance as a
character part of what i liked about him
was
this was basically a prequel
to a laura danon's story i.e the baby
the cho the baby is the chosen one he's
just he's just protecting her and
theoretically the truly important stuff
as far as the world is concerned happens
when she grows up so i kind of hope that
they if they're gonna keep willow around
they're gonna have him be smaller scale
not make him massively important that
would be the one thing i'm afraid of but
as long as i don't do that i'm really
interested i mentioned star wars we're
getting the obi-wan kenobi show which
i've been curious for a while and
honestly it's mostly just to see you and
mcgregor play the part again um i'm a
little nervous because uh the
promo art that we saw did feature darth
vader granted it was concept art maybe
he's not showing up but if he's not
showing up it would have been very
foolish for them to tease the idea that
he was story-wise that makes me nervous
because i kind of just want this to be
obi-wan's story not have it get overly
bogged down on anakin as if he never had
anything going on in his life at any
point other than just dealing with
anakin in some way shape or form but i
really do like ewan mcgregor in this
part and i know there have been
concepts and ideas for something with
him to reprise this part whether it be
film or streaming for
years so let's finally see what this
pays out to be
we've got multiple shows coming in the
mcu but out of the ones there and there
are some ones that like are of
characters i love i love ms marvel i'm
curious to see how moon knight goes but
i'll tell you the one that i am legit
truly deeply excited for
she-hulk
not only do i love the character of
she-hulk
they got tatiana maslany who is a
phenomenal
actress to play the part
and and they seem to be focusing on the
legal aspects which means they're taking
their cues from my favorite kinds of
she-hulk stories focusing on her
practicing law
and superhero related law in specific i
love that i said
years and years ago that i wanted to see
she-hulk but i thought it would make a
better tv show
than a movie and
we're getting it
i've said i've wanted this
for years
please be good netflix has a number of
things coming out uh but the three that
i am most excited for not the only
things i plan to watch but the three i'm
most excited for are cabinet of
curiosities aka 10 after midnight now
this is guillermo del toro working a
horror i believe it's planned to be an
anthology style show
i will give basically anything guillermo
del toro cares to put his name on at
least a shot because
the man just does amazing work i love
his aesthetics i like his story
instincts i want to see what he's going
to do here there's going to be some kind
of follow-up to castlevania which i am
both excited and nervous about excited
because i really loved castlevania
loved that series so much
um nervous because
that entire series was written by warren
ellis who is not going to be involved in
the follow-up now i get why i'm not
saying he should be i remember
everything that went on
with that and i think it's good that he
is continuing to step away
from the limelight and from these kinds
of projects that's for the best for
everybody involved including him if i'm
gonna be completely honest but knowing
that he was so central to the to those
scripts that he wrote every episode it
just makes me nervous
are they gonna get somebody else who's
gonna get it as well
i hope so i hope so because at the very
least they'll have this previous stuff
that's already been done as a template
to work off of they're not going to be
working in the dark but
oh god i want it to be good i mean
granted it can't taint the original four
seasons for castlevania those are locked
in but you know
uh
i want more and i wanted to be good and
then finally we have the netflix
adaptation of sandman
i am most curious for this because i am
hoping
that they're going to do something a
little bit different with it than just a
straight adaptation of the comic because
like look if you know my stuff at all
you know i'm a little iffy on super
loyal adaptations because i find them
redundant if you're gonna be super loyal
then i might as well just enjoy the
original you know now i do get that you
know sometimes it's a new medium people
are experiencing it for the first time
and to a certain extent i get that
except that in the case of sandman we
have and it's still ongoing i believe
we're actually going to get another
volume of it this year
if we are consider that on the list um
but the sandman audio drama which has a
full cast and that is the comic done
directly virtually no alterations at all
so we already have a super loyal version
for anybody who wasn't up for reading
the comic
for this
i don't need a third version that is
virtually identically the same
please have the guts to do things a
little like don't change it from the
ground up but just do something a little
different and just looking at some of
the casting choices gives me some hope
that okay
okay
maybe
i love the original sandman a lot and i
have a decent amount of faith in neil
gaiman so
i'm still hopeful for this over on hbo
max they have a number of things that i
wish i was excited for but
i'm kind of not like house of the dragon
westworld season four i feel like i
should be excited for those i'm just not
though there are a few things i am a bit
more excited about peacemaker i am
probably gonna check out i'm not like
super pumped because the funny thing is
i enjoyed the suicide squad quite a bit
but it didn't stick
uh if you saw my video on my favorite
stuff from last year it didn't make the
list proper because it just didn't leave
nearly as much of a lasting impression
as i would have hoped again i liked it
at the moment but it kind of went in one
ear and went out the other so i'm not
expecting a lasting impact from
peacemaker but i expect it to be fun and
i'm pretty confident it will be we're
also going to be getting uh hopefully
another season of harley quinn i love
harley quinn i have recently gotten my
partner into it she loves harley quinn i
am definitely up for more that show is
very fun i love these iterations of the
characters i really want to see what
they do with harley and ivy just don't
do the stupid freaking thing where you
like break them up or have tensions
right away so that you go back to the
chemistry they had before like let it
let them exist as a couple please please
please and then finally the one other
thing from hbo max
time traveler's wife now i read that
book a while back really liked that book
the movie that already came out was
um
but what interests me most about this is
that stephen moffat is the person behind
it
now on the one hand if you know doctor
who that should seem like an obvious oh
well he's done time travel before that's
why they brought him on for this yes but
that's not actually why i'm super
excited because if moffat had a weakness
it was that he wasn't he could do it
sometimes but he wasn't always reliably
good at nailing down the emotional
through line or the emotional
connections between characters i think
he leaned on the actors to kind of pull
the weight on that quite a bit thing is
though time traveler's wife
has
really good emotionally driven
characters in it already so as long as
he casts correctly
the fullness of these characters is
already laid out for him and he can
focus more on adapting the
time-bendingness of the novel to a
mini-series or whatever this ends up
being so i think this is potentially a
really good match of creator to material
not just because he's done
um time travel stuff before but because
stuff that's already good about the book
as long as he doesn't mess with it it
could actually make up for some of the
weaknesses he tends to have sometimes as
a writer so for that reason i'm kind of
excited and finally let's talk about
what's coming to theaters and
yeah this is going to be pretty much all
superhero related stuff look like i said
there's other stuff that i'm gonna need
to see trailer before i know whether or
not i think it looks any good and
there's smaller films that i just i know
nothing about at this point it'll
probably be good but this is the stuff
that is catching my eye right now so
there's uh doctor strange
in the multiverse of madness uh i am i'm
definitely up for this i mean a big part
of it is the fact that sam raimi's
directing it i won't lie the idea of him
coming back to superhero movies i love
that notion
and the trailer did look pretty
interesting again i don't love the fact
that it looks like it's making that one
episode of what if uh even more canon
than what if has already been implied to
be just by the existence of the
multiverse but i think
i could probably
work with that and i do like benedict
cumberbatch in this role i like wanda i
know i have my issues with blonde
division but i do still like her as a
character and i want to see i want to
see what they actually plan to do with
the multiverse because so far the
multiverse has largely been a matter of
introducing it as an idea
with things like loki and the multiverse
in terms of uh alternate timelines and
with things like what if but now we've
had the idea introduced
what kind of story is you actually going
to tell with it
and that's what i'm going to be curious
to see there's also going to be thor
love and thunder taika watiti's coming
back i expect this to be fun
um while i didn't think she was one of
the high points of the first thor movie
i do like jane foster as thor in the
comics and i do like natalie portman
often not always but often in film and
yeah i want to i want to see what
someone like taiko watiti is going to do
with that storyline very curious let's
toss in one dc movie here just to throw
a bone and honestly this is more morbid
curiosity than anything else but the
flash
for everything they've got going on with
it they seem to be swinging big on it
and they've been trying to get this
thing made for so
long it's ridiculous but this is the one
i think i have the most
curiosity about i'm kind of like you
know what if they can remember to keep
it fun
and quick paced which you need to be for
a flash movie
yeah maybe
be super curious for a trailer i'll tell
you that
finally
across the spider verse
into the spider verse
one of the very best movies of that year
i personally think it's the best
spider-man movie any made it ever made
it might be the best superhero movie
ever made
yeah i'm excited for a sequel normally
i'd be more nervous like you're
following up with something that was so
good how are you going to top that but
you know then i saw the trailer and
there's my boy miguel o'hara spider-man
2099 my favorite spider-man
oh
like this one pretty much everything
else you've heard me saying over and
over and over again i'm hopeful looks
interesting i hope it's good you know
cautious optimism this one
full-blown excitement for this one
i cannot wait
so pumped
but those are my picks
what about you what things on streaming
services i didn't name what movies i
didn't mention what video games whatever
whatever it is you're excited to uh take
in
this year in terms of entertainment let
me hear about it maybe you'll
turn my attention to something that
would interest me that i missed when
looking up what was coming out this year
but whatever your thoughts are drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it i got a patreon
it keeps this whole operation up and
running uh there's a link for it down in
the description as well as well as links
to the other things i do on the internet
twitch instagram tick tock et cetera et
cetera et cetera don't worry too much
about that though because the like
shares subscribes they help me out too
if you want to go that way but even if
you aren't up for that it is okay
because
at the end of the day
you are the council
i just run the meetings and until next
time
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
thanks for sticking around into the
credits none of this would have been
possible without my patreon supporters
in particular i want to thank robin
powell tracy scrabbit vincent paul
partolucci robin moore jayla gourle and
bookworm
thanks for keeping this going and to
everybody
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
now
[Music]